comme un feu d'artifices dans la nuit
d'hier pin à quelques kilomètres de kiev
des traînées blanches
incandescente qui tombe lentement vers
le sol
ces images filmées avant-hier par un
journaliste anglais serait selon
plusieurs experts le signe de bombes au
phosphore blanc la même scène a été
photographiée de cette fenêtre et
publiées sur les réseaux sociaux par le
maire dira pin que nous venons de
joindre
grâce à dieu les bombes sont tombées à
300 400 mètres de nos positions ils ont
manqué leur cible heureusement il n'ya
pas eu de blessés ni de mort avec le
phosphore
les armes au phosphore ne sont pas
interdites mais leur usage en milieu
urbain contre des civils pourraient être
assimilées à des crimes de guerre
d'autres villes comme pop hasna is you
mme héroux busines aurait également été
touchées ces derniers jours
sur ce document daté du 13 mars on y
voit se tirent dans le ciel ça tombe là
bas puis c'est même traîné scintillante
[Musique]
qu'il tire du phosphore sur la ville sur
roudet le président ukrainien à accuser
les russes d'avoir utilisé du phosphore
pour tuer des femmes et des enfants
selon cet expert le kremlin avait déjà
utilisé cette arme en chine au phosphore
brûle à une température extrêmement
élevée jusqu'à 1300 degré et donc peut
provoquer évidemment des incendies mais
des brûlures extrêmement graves et
mortels sur les populations civiles
exposés et donc elles ont un caractère
de terrorisation évidemment très marqué
ces bombes ont été largement utilisés
dans des conflits dans le passé comme en
irak ou à gaza
en ukraine des enquêtes ont été ouvertes
pour recueillir des preuves seule
l'analyse de résidus pourra déterminer
avec certitude la nature de ces
munitions la russie de son côté nie
toute implication